hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Minotaur now this is a
point-and-click puzzle adventure game
but this is just an early phase demo
it's uh no no no it seems to have a lot
of really nice art so I'm gonna play
it's not here so nice hi my name is nod
call me nod do gangster pikes
it's nod there we go I'm awake now is
gonna happen that hurts
maybe it saw the wires going into your
brain there you've slept for so long and
you still reek of booze I can't drink it
you know that I have to rub it all over
my body it's the only way I can get a
high how can you tell Holly I never
installed any smell receptors I can
practically see it that doesn't make any
sense at all pull yourself together and
head out your night shift at the factory
starts in half an hour ok what does that
mean oh oh crap didn't you wake me up
earlier yeah why you know not not wake
up my calculations okay sure yeah ok I'm
so glad I made up anime robot with the
SAS you really need some tuning Ollie
alright
I have to get going my boss will never
get off my ass mmm kinky
alright let's go to it so in-game menu
sweet Cal and I remember taking us homes
have Irene in our local club demons
armpit just three years ago your local
club Oh a successful Club is it
performing on a stage of supernova Oh
super and over a much better name for a
club should be happy for Wow yesterday
all over again
ah ok drinking to forget a password
Beast this these don't make any sense
bash what is that it's one of two
alignment days
it's a very significant day wait that's
one of two alignment days when Hades and
Logan both our stars rise up and go down
at the same time okay it's a very all
right cool
do you have information about every
single one of these days or do I have to
find the red ones all right whatever
okay now let's see what else we got
balcony door you would know them at
least I can't hear Ollie from here yeah
gross I think is that is that what the
boy team has never attacked trains
demons you say demons brands are the
only way to move safely between dome
cities dome cities Oh Mac systems have
shielded us from demons for almost five
centuries demons I don't remember the
name of the woman who invented them we
all over our lives it's like the Final
Fantasy movie oh it's super weird okay
oh he who brings plague hmm I heard this
demon recently became active in parts
around Nova just look at him I could
never understand people who go outside
domes willingly bunch of freaks looking
for freedom and the whatnot and whathave
you not for me not at all never actually
glitchy
right a used one too well that would
probably imply that it was the cheapest
it's not it I think something's wrong
with our access power grid hmm maybe I
should turn the panel off just in case
okay did that all right what have we got
here is that a gun I'm working on a
dolly
you know what's expensive clients for
weapon enhancements without the firm
I'm just that good yeah yeah okay yeah
and I guess who your clients have
special reasons to work with someone who
doesn't keep official records uh-huh
okay I love the backgrounds oh nice like
the artwork is really nice and
everything's animated it's almost
completely silent but lacks firepower
and I'm supposed to take care of that
okay you need a loud kaboom er on it
there's your problem it's not loud
enough everyone knows lethality okay ah
whoa items are used auto magically okay
what does that have to do with what I'm
doing here though wait a second I feel
like I'm forgetting something
ah yes the gun not forgot like I'm being
guided by some invisible hand don't make
a meta joke in here what am i doing
maybe you should take a closer look at
those triangular nodes on the left
before leaving maybe I should not that a
good idea the invisible hand never lies
uh-huh
yeah what about that are you the
invisible hand or am I the invisible
hand because frankly you're talking to
yourself about an invisible hand that
gave yourself a suggestion so you think
that that's what's guiding you through
this adventure right I'm out here to
figure out what the hell's going on with
everything else going on Lydia can I
leave that looks bad Oh butt up big
brother to advent days
something to make your code up you're
not very good at starting from scratch
and I mean that on so many levels
I know what it is is probably these days
so it's two zero one eight I bet that's
it two zero one eight two thousand
eighteen zero one how about you stop
laughing at me and be useful you're damn
robot bomb storage unit
LD twelve say and they almost talked me
into buying a d24 haha those scoundrels
those scoundrels look at that right now
what about some of the hair those dog
the bid the you know the saying the hair
dog biting that thing remember that can
I use that on anything the whip all
right so what did that do and I leave
the cake I don't like where this is
going but yes do you want me to call the
police what what why because the
security alarm that's why I'm home beats
me I see nothing here worth taking
including you wow you got drunk and
started mumbling about how this Arthur
guy from upstairs was after you so Holly
I don't remember the code well you did
yesterday please let me out
no can do security protocol and all that
Holly you know I'm already late for work
please
no please disable the alarm first mr.
pikes or I'll have to call the police
damn robots who knows what they'll say
about that little outfitting shop you
run here Oh like you wouldn't get
confiscated to assistant are you damn
you or okay how do you do that you can
just tell me if you miss me mr. Pike's
well I'm I'm just saying
I really don't let's look for something
that holds sentimental value or life
that's mostly right hey shut up about me
and my personal problems you leave me
and me alone
shut up I didn't sassy robot no
neighbors still yes your ex and her rich
husband living right above you that's
not cool that's weird
throw this picture away and move
someplace else while you're at it that's
some good advice not not gonna listen to
you not gonna drink away Nod sorrows and
shut you up later as soon as I remember
the code did ask me to get rid of it
recently someone told Arthur about it
and they made him furious yeah yeah
tomorrow how about tomorrow that's also
good well I'll click on this all boy I
got a screwdriver for this lamp a
strange journey
those are good days yeah in yes 23 the
best probably you'll ever have not ain't
gonna have no better days than that with
Maya then when then when I had with my
ex that's how sad I am ha ha ha train
journey yes 23 ok so I got to look for
uh I know what I need to do is yes one
of these weird and yes 23:21 know that
mm z n
z and 23
well this is the 600 6-2 306 2 3
good it Bo 6 2 3 I'm really impressed no
you're not like I said preemptively shut
up wait till I come back College you'll
see how much I learned an AI tuning
class yeah blabber rabble rabble rabble
rabble why yell at me for a tutor to set
a running world record right who runs in
this time okay what the Hades not know
understand what that is oh the day
before okay what's happening the day
before no it's me
just let me in what about all those
repurposing threats baby shut up X of
mine that I love oh yeah please stop
calling me baby come on naughty
water under the bridge naughty didn't
know my name was naughty like a swamp
ah ha Polly I'm fine Irene I just forgot
my key at the factory yeah true no I
don't want you to ask Arthur I'll figure
something out good thing you gave the
context of the sentence that came prior
before that or else we wouldn't have any
idea what was happening
see thanks Ally uh-huh nod wait I need
to talk to you about something sure is
it about how you love me and this man
would you would you like to come in not
really
no thanks cool squalor in there anyway
you wouldn't want to see it guys crying
a region wine from one of my clients you
could talk about old times
nope do that that sounds depressing like
when you first got your synthetic chords
and they tune them wrong disaster demons
armpit demons arm that's so upset and
drunk that I had to carry home come on
yeah sorry what did you want to talk
about could Arthur buy the whole
building now wants to evict me it's
related to him yes
you know how he's uncomfortable with us
being friends totally not my problem
yeah I understand it's difficult for me
too he can be jealous sometimes that's
an understatement I know we fight about
it often in fact the last time was only
a couple of days ago it wasn't about you
specifically
but it came up that you still have that
photo from our vacation in Mira yeah
like friends you know all friends
piggyback off each other's backs all the
time and then piggy front later in the
hotel things like that happen
wait you can't be serious I am please
nod this is ridiculous ridiculous I love
that photo I look at it every night
right before I go to bed just get rid of
that photo trust me it's better this way
much better
oh thanks ollie for your unneeded help
your unwavering support is such [ __ ]
shut up ollie I can't handle this in my
emotions maturely
Oh Arthur Oh God no less in conversation
am i interrupting
my talk here in the corridor go on have
a drink at his place well if you say so
he invited you what if I did you're
controlling freak stop it nod you too
Arthur could not just forgot his key and
needed help but it's it's fine now we're
leaving come on let's go you don't have
to ask me twice
I came here for you not the other way
around
Oh Oh God do what I asked you to please
uh-huh
Oh time to get drunk hate that guy I
wonder wha but something tells me that
maybe the the relationship falling apart
wasn't entirely Arthur's fault in this
endeavor oh oh oh look at that
ooh oh look at her
that's great Oh wowie Zowie yep look
look at it every night right before I go
to bed and Ollie is always there
watching and judging how creepy I am and
how I can't move on you robo is that
Arthur Oh what are you doing there is
that a guitar that's awesome
it's an awesome penguin
ah this looks so cool I don't think the
full game is out though like that I am
pretty sure this is just a hey okay
[Music]
that's the name of the game
okay there you have it that anyway Oh
chapter 2 I didn't even know there was
gonna be a chapter 2 Oh Baby Doe ladies
I'm Logan
that's not something you see every day
no it is not sure the Royce building was
a dump but I never thought it would just
start falling apart one day no way to
the passenger elevators is blocked but
Maya has a hover car she often arcs it
outside her place to fill it up I hope
that she's at home uh-huh how could I've
slept through that I don't know you were
really drunk
he always writing it's time to cut back
on the drinking yeah see the guiding
hand knows what sue
speaking of guiding hand holy [ __ ] yes
it's not Irene she performs tonight oh
that's my only concern the waste of
human life means nothing so long as it's
not Irene in bracelets either she never
goes anywhere without those yeah it's
definitely not Irene this poor a
suspecting person under a pile of rubble
whoa that's a load off my mind Oh Maya
who's Maya best stop guessing no good
will come of it yeah okay yeah best not
to tell any about it either he's shut
yeah only geosynthetic arm I'm not a
bulldozer Arthur's a bulldozer you know
no hmm
all right fine man what are we supposed
to do about this olly olly olly olly
olly olly olly olly olly olly olly olly
olly oh yeah often forgets the locker
door so let's just barge right in and a
scatterbrain
maybe it's the same thing come on dear
no response hmm oh she's all right
yeah not crushed under that pile no
matter if I just go in your home Maya
Oh window filters work fine no surprise
there
that was the one who installed them yeah
I'm such a sham to think of it that
works me to the bone I hope she won't
mind if I look around yeah seems like a
fair exchange Oh
Banzai he's freaking me out all right
fine is everything cool freak something
unnatural about them yeah unnatural
about that says the guy with the Robo
arm and a robo neck Irene likes them
though maybe I should have gotten her
one about Irene not get over it what we
got here car seems to be a work in
progress must be one of Maya's models
for clients uh-huh
can I ruin it oh can I ruin it oh can I
ruin it's a key whoa started locking it
after someone tried to handle fuses and
burn one of them probably Maya though
yeah probably best to just take her
stuff I shouldn't be doing this why am I
just messing with someone else's
painting or doing that instead of
outfitting no I'm gonna keep doing this
go for that sweets and what kind of it
kind of make her baby boom ha ha take
that that was for no reason that nothing
is weird about that now that would have
been weirder but hon for no reason just
ha ha it's in the wrong place is it good
is it bad up let's just forget anything
happened here move on with our lives
everybody just delete that from your
brain what just happened there and we'll
just carry on like nothing happened
because nothing did Paco sunny woo Hades
in Logan
their unique cycle greatly influences
way of life on the planet
ooh alrighty then bars control oh let me
just steal her car why not I've taken
everything else I'll be right back I'm
gonna make sure that I got everything
aqua massed outside domes these species
constantly jump between realities I
think what what is what you want to run
that by me again looks nice I think it's
from the dome city of Tolly uh why
arenas from there to in fact I think it
was a gift from her Tamiya okay all
right everything always leads back to
the marine Irene a little bit something
strange is going on no kick back relax
have a drink I thought she was pregnant
with Irene's baby all right where's this
lockbox that he was talking about what
are we looking for where we're going
barrels
barrels having access stations like this
and residential buildings is not quite
legal good I installed it anyway
compared to my unregistered workbench
this is just a misunderstanding
yeah sure okay having a station like
that is really convenient
we charge things without paying a single
lot okay all right well that's good I
guess I don't know let's take a look
inside why not not like it was a dead
body behind me to turn my access vision
on sure okay I don't know what that is
it the implant at first when they
practically forced me to install out of
the factory yeah it turned out to be
quite a useful overlay especially for
outfitting jobs
my boss was right for once
uh-huh okay well as these no it's
madness for me should help me figure out
what I'm routing power to I don't even
know what I'm routing power to but it
seems like a car is there so I guess I
couldn't have driven the car without it
hmm oh let's get uh
huh well that one's burnt out right
there so this is no going for that ah I
think I know I know I think I get it
Oh
[Music]
I had to push the button for the overlay
I didn't funneling with it for like ten
minutes and I was like I don't get this
this doesn't make any sense this overlay
isn't as good as this boss not anything
dude all right so uh okay
I think I understand what's going on
here I think I got a an inkling yeah
that's the right stuff oh that's the
good stuff
oh that's good stuff well that's good
stuff all right ah there's one thing all
right
so I don't know what the teeth coming
out of the demon is but I'm gonna go
find out what the the teeth and the
demon thing is all about
oh so that would have been over there I
only have a sin once upon a time I can't
get through there okay so that's not
gonna help me at all for some reason and
I don't think I can do the other thing
because it's all rusted oh it no it's
not oh no it's not a power station
what station what Stacey did I just
power up I don't know what I'm working
but I don't have anything on me that
needs charging do I need to go get
though do I need to go get like a power
cell from the thing guess I cut off
power to the Inca tow port ow okay well
whatever about the hover car ah let's
get out of here I just need to calm down
and then it's a five minute walk to Nova
Corps station doesn't even start Oh grab
it I already know your face might still
work goodbye peace and quiet
Oh hikes I can't believe it are you
finally taking me out go all the time
uh-huh what are you my girlfriend I had
something very special planned just help
me fix the car and we'll get there
well the onboard battery is dead let me
start with that the cause is mechanical
try looking around the car thanks ollie
you're so nice connector socket for the
onboard battery someone tried to rip it
out maybe it was broken and Maya tried
to fix it herself
instead of using your cheap labor I
highly doubt it besides one would need
to be freakishly strong to do something
like that Wow I found something I don't
know what I found my foundry here that's
what I just asked nod if you get your
head out of your ass and stop talking
all that way a portable access container
thank you ollie I know what it is ollie
that was a rhetorical question yeah well
maybe you shouldn't asked it nod
I wasn't sure mr. Pike's nibs nod I'm
saying worried you're losing touch with
reality I am talking to a virtual
reality assistant so Holly
one day I'll pick your blue box apart to
know why hmm
anyway Maya probably uses it to charge
her paint guns it's a cheap thing but it
might be useful so I better hold on to
it
yeah better all down to this useless
junk that I'm stealing from my own hook
a pack to the battery oh oh charged aah
so hence why the thing over in the
thing--the honor and the the free leech
of power dude adder that I got also that
dead body still there let's plug this
still there that cable fit in there I
don't know what are you talking about no
I can try and start the onboard battery
yeah also still forgetting dead body
right there right there on the ground
it's blood is oozing towards me and I'm
worried about getting to work why
haven't I called the police
oh yeah because my apartment is full of
gun all right
anyway I'm angry for no reason I'm not
even angry what do you think I'm angry
I'm not angry vision all right I gotta
get this over to the other thing so that
I can go I think there's something about
a car there so I'm only assuming that
that's what that is how do I owe this
ones approval Oh cuz it's not right way
well how would you make that nut uh
y-you know not right way no wait I'm
dumb what am i doing why didn't I just
oh I didn't even realize I had two of
those oh god I'm so stupid
I just Oh God think the pump charger on
the balcony is on now ah the pump
charger that I didn't even look at but
it took me forever to get turn up blue
vision right Maya hope you don't mind me
going through your place once more
alright I got our hover car Ollie let's
go we must be inside let's try hooking
up back to it okay hey that seems bad
corn see if it worked
okay Hong Kong thousand times to never
leave the car with the tank empty damn
you you pregnant lady I'm gonna be mad
at you and mess with your painting some
or should probably be offended but it
does feel that way yeah it's a good
thing I installed an access pump for and
hooked it up to her power grid well good
thing I just connected that now didn't I
fuel the car with it okay well I just
did that so Oh get this show on the road
yeah I don't need to wait for it to
charging its supernova after I talked to
the cops you shouldn't do that
I heard some caste was saved I damned
not over my ex oh I think it came from
the hallway damn it
the access is gone I've got a bad
feeling about this but I need to check
back on the panel how about that dead
body while you were humming about not
dead bodies huh
you ever think about that for one guy Oh
something's definitely wrong with our
axis critic
I guess my free lunch is over I think I
did manage to squeeze in a little I need
to go back and try to work with what I
got good thing well he didn't hear that
she'd say this should be my life's motto
how did all he not hear that that was a
freaking explosion also did that body
call me loser that up before Nova cores
android start asking questions about
this whole setup yeah no all right well
time to go I guess or do I need what do
I need to do I forgotten what you
actually needed to do I was too worried
about the dead body
Ollie locked me up again I think I
forgot the code yes I did the guiding
hand says yes okay so what was going on
there oh my I probably should have asked
that before I barged in and messed with
your painting I'll come back for her
later hmm yeah you didn't hear that
explosion or the hallway collapsing cuz
that's you know that's a thing that
happened that keeps herself in shape
yeah she does girl but she doesn't quite
fit in what shape does she keep herself
in huh good joke me or anyway bars no
bars it is great at Amaya but the view
from here is so much better than from my
place ah screw that industrial charm I
want to see the inner district
people they're well off oh yeah
they don't have their girlfriends leave
them for Arthur's oh not sad all right
Holly
help help help be are you taking me
no but here we go can we go dude alright
here's the plan
the car will probably move just a few
leagues but we should reach that balcony
I don't know whose apartment that is but
it's supposed to connect to the cargo
elevator hallway ah cargo elevator
operates in a backup axis generator so
hopefully it still works and I'll be
able to get down you just talking to
yourself or you open that somebody else
here to the moon Oh No nailed it that's
not a euphemism warned you and now I
have to go you're a selfish man mr. pike
oh thanks ollie it's going to be my way
nothing all right let's get out of here
purgatory hello you made it so far this
is my room
this is where my story begins oh this is
where the demo ends I was into it I was
so into it
The Adventures of Nod oh let's click
this button do it hurry with jeez calm
down there whoa I don't know if I want
to click that okay well I guess that's
the end of the demo so thank you
everybody so much for watching
oh I'm sorry I have these uncontrollable
burst of rage from time to time I'm
pretty [ __ ] up anyway thank you for
playing this demo we appreciate your
feedback so come see us when tell us
what you think
bye hope we meet again alrighty then
there you have it there's some extras in
there that's really cool that is really
cool I like that a lot so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought its down in the
comments below and I actually am very
much looking forward to a full release
of this game
it was very exposition a full in the
demo obviously but it did set a good
tone to it like when I was looking at
the screenshots for the skin
here get when I was looking at the
screenshot for this game I wasn't too
sure about it but now that I played it
like it's one of those things that you
have to play to really get the feel of
it and I really do appreciate it so
thank you again let me know what you
think and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]